you know there are american heroes
who don't like this idea neil armstrong
gene cernan have both testified against
commercial space flight and the way that
you're developing it
and i wonder what you think of that i
was very sad to see that
um because those guys are yeah
you know those guys are heroes of mine
so it's really tough
you know i i wish they would come and
visit and and see the hardware that
we're doing here
i think that would change their mind
they inspired you to do this didn't they
yes and to see them casting stones in
your direction difficult
did you expect them to cheer you on
so they hoping they would what are you
trying to prove to them
what i'm trying to do is to make a
significant difference
in in space flight and and and
help make space flight accessible to to
almost anyone
2008 was brutal um yeah 2008 we had
the third consecutive failure of the
falcon rocket for spacex
um tesla
almost went bankrupt we closed our
financing round
p.m christmas eve 2008 it was the last
hour of the last day that it was
possible
we would have gone bankrupt two days
after christmas otherwise
and i got divorced that was like rough
man
if things just gone a little bit the
other way both companies would be dead
and i like one of the most difficult
choices i have ever faced
uh in life was was in 2008
um and um
i think i had uh like
maybe 30 million dollars left or 30 or
41 left in 2008 i had two choices
i could put it all into one company
and then the other company would
definitely die or split it
between the two companies and but if i
split up between two companies then both
might die
and when you put your blood sweat and
tears
into creating something you're building
something it's like a child
and so it's like which one am i going to
let one starve to death
i can bring myself to do it so i split
the money between the two
fortunately thank goodness uh they both
came through
um they said
as a support for spacex first three
launches failed
and uh we were just barely able to
scrape
together enough parts and money to do
the
the fourth launch that fourth launch had
failed we would have been dead
so multiple failures along the way um
i tried very hard to to get the right
expertise in for
for spacex i tried hard to to find a
great
uh chief engineer for the rocket but it
not the good chief engineers wouldn't
join
and the bad ones well there was no no
point in hiring them so i ended up being
chief engineer of the rocket
so if i could have found somebody better
than we would have maybe had
less than three failures
when you had that third failure in a row
did you think i need to pack this in
never
why not i don't ever give up
i mean i'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated
but there are a lot of negative things
in the world there's a lot of terrible
things that are happening
all over the world all the time
uh there are lots of problems that need
to get sold there's lots of things that
are
yeah they're miserable and kind of get
you down but that
life cannot just be about solving one
miserable problem after another can't
that can't be the only thing
they need to be need to be things that
inspire you
that make you glad to be to wake up in
the morning and be part of humanity
that's why we did this
this guy called sielkovsky one of the
early russian
rocket scientists the great saying earth
is the cradle of humanity but you cannot
stay in the cradle forever
it is time to go forth become a
star-faring civilization be out there
among the stars
expand the scope and scale of human
consciousness
i find that incredibly exciting
that makes me glad to be alive
i hope you feel the same way
there's certain things that are
necessary to ensure that the future is
good
and
some of those things are in the long
term having
long-term sustainable transport and
sustainable energy generation
and to be a space-bearing civilization
and for humanity to be out there among
the stars and
be a multi-planetary species
i mean i think the being a multi-planet
species and being out there among the
stars is important for
the long-term survival of humanity
and that's one reason kind of like life
insurance for life collectively
life as we know it but then the
part that i find personally most
motivating
is that it creates a sense of adventure
and it makes people excited about the
future
and if you consider two futures one
where we are forever confined to earth
until eventually something terrible
happens
or another future where we are out there
on
many planets maybe even going beyond the
solar system
i think that second version is
incredibly exciting and inspiring
how do you choose your team based on
what
well um i suppose honestly that
it tends to be gut feel more than
anything else
so when i interview somebody
my interview question is always the same
it's just
i said tell me the story of your life
and and the decisions that you made
along the way and why you made them
and then um
if and and also tell me about some of
the most difficult problems you worked
on
and how you solved them and
that that that question i think is very
important because
the people that really solve the problem
they know
exactly how they solved it they know the
little details
and the people that pretended to solve
the problem they can maybe go one level
and then they get stuck
i mean you just have to put in you know
80 hour
80 to 100 hour weeks every week
all those things improve the odds of
success okay particularly if you're
starting a company you need to work
super hard
so what what does super hard mean um
well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company
instead of getting an apartment we just
rented us a small office
and we slept on the couch and we
we showered at the the ymca and uh we're
so hot up we had just
one computer so the the website was up
during the day
and i was coding at night seven days a
week all the time
the final thing i would encourage you to
do is now is the time to take risk
as you get older your obligations
increase so
and once you have a family you start
taking risk not just for yourself but
for your family as well it gets much
harder
to do things that might not work out
um so now is the time to do that uh
before you before you have those
obligations so i would encourage you to
take risks now do something bold
you won't regret it thank you
[Music]
you